[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مستمرون معكم في تغطيه
للانتخابات والنصفيه الامريكيه حيث يواصل
الناخبون الادلاء باصواتهم وقد فتحت مراكز
الاقتراع ابوابها اتباعا منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى وكان اكثر من 40 مليون شخص قد له
باصواتهم خلال التصويت المبكر في جميع
انحاء
[موسيقى]
وفي فيلادلفيا اكبر مدن ولايه بنسلفانيا
اوضح مسؤولون ان فرز الاصوات سيستغرق وقتا
اطول من المتوقع بعد منعطف اللحظه الاخيره
لاعاده فرز الاصوات القادمه عبر البريد
العمليه التي وصفتها صحيفه
فيلادلفيارور بانها ستستغرق وقتا طويلا
وستطلب جهدا
[موسيقى]
صور درويش
قبل ذلك قالت رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
ناسيوس في مقابله مع سي ان ان الامريكيه
قالت ان الهجوم الوحشيه على زوجها سيؤثر
على قرارها بشان البقاء في الكونجرس بعد
انتخابات التجديد النصفي كما دعت بلوسي
الجمهوريين الى وقف المعلومات المظلله
التي تغذي العنف السياسي وحفت الامريكيين
على التصويت للدفاع عن الديمقراطيه فيما
لم تكشف بروسيا عن خطتها المستقبليه اذا
خسر الحزب الديمقراطي الاغلبيه في مجلس
النواب حيث يعتقد الكثيرون ان فلوسي
واخرين سيتناحون عن السلطه
او المراه الحديديه كما توصف هي وجه
الديمقراطيين اللامع لعقدين من الزمن في
لوسي تفكر باسدال الستار على مهمتها في
الخدمه العامه فمع مستقبل سياسي غير واضح
وانتخابات تهدد اغلبيه الديمقراطيين في
مجلس النواب والاعتداء على زوجها كل ذلك
قال كاهله اول امراه تتبوا هذا المنصب
الرفيع اعتبرها العديد من الخبراء اقوى
رؤساء مجلس النواب منذ اكثر من 100 عام
حيث تراست الديمقراطيين الذين خسروا
الاغلبيه في عام 2010 ثم بقيت على راس
المؤتمر الحزبي وقددتهم الى السلطه مجددا
في العام 2018
نهايه هذا العام ليتهافت الطامحون على
خلافتها للحصول على دعمها قبل حتى ان تقرر
وقد راى متابعون ان بيلوسي ربما اتخذت
قرارها منذ اشهر وبالتحديد منذ زيارتها
الى تايوان التي صاحبها انتقادات حاده من
بكين بل ومن وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
نفسها
وسواء كانت النتيجه فوزه او خساره
الاغلبيه لا شك ان بيلوسي تركت بالفعل
بصمه تاريخيه على مجلس النواب والكونجرس
والامه الامريكيه بحسب ما تقول واشنطن
بوست
[موسيقى]
باور رينجرز
هذا وقدم الرئيس جوبيدون تقييما صريحا
لفراس حزبه في الاحتفاظ بالسيطره على مجلس
سيء النواب والشيوخ قبيل الساعات من
انطلاق انتخابات التجديد النصفي في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
البنك
[موسيقى]
واتس واتس
في غضون ذلك اظهر استطلاع وراي اجرته
رويترز بالتزامن مع انطلاق الانتخابات
النصفيه اظهرا انخفاض شعبيه الرئيس هذا
الاسبوع لتقترب من ادنى مستوياتها خلال
فتره رئاسه
وخلص الاستطلاع الذي اجري على مدار يومين
تراجع شعبيه الرئيس الامريكي الى 39%
ويعزز تراجع شعبيه التوقعات بان يفوز
الجمهوريون بالسيطره على مجلس النواب ومن
المحتمل ايضا مجلس الشيوخ ما سيمنحهم
السلطه لتعطيل جدول
التشريعي وسط مشاكل اقتصاديه نتيجه
تتداعيات الجارحه العالميه ابرزها ارتفاع
الطبخ
ويدخل الرئيس الامريكي ضد الانتخابات
النصفيه وهو يضع حسبه في موقف صعب للغايه
شعبيه الرجل اخذه في تاكل والسبب الرئيسي
في هذا يعود الى الاقتصاد نقطه ضعفه
الكبير
قبل الانتخابات انتقد بايضا قرار ابك بلاس
بخفض انتاج النفط
ذلك لانه حاول خفض الاسعار ليدخل
الانتخابات وبيده ورقه ترابحه دون
الالتفات الى الحاجه الحقيقيه للسوق
ومصلحه الاقتصاد العالمي
دخول الجوبايدن المكتبه البيضاوي قرر
الرئيس السادس والاربعون وقفه منحي تراخيص
واذونات جديده للتنقيب عن النفط والغاز في
الاراضي الفدراليه مشكله اولى من صنع يد
الرئيس فاقمها بمشكله الثانيه قرار بضرب
مشروع انابيب كيستون الاستراتيجي مع كندا
الذي يستطيع نقل تقريبا نحو مليون برميل
يوميا الى ساحل خليج الولايات المتحده
اوقفه كما اشرنا بعد ان اجازه الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب ضمن استراتيجيه
ادارته لتعزيز امن الطاقه في امريكا
اكثر من ذلك قاوم بعد الضغوط التي مارستها
كندا على الولايات المتحده لاحياء خط
انابيب كيستون اكس ال تعويضا عن الامدادات
الروسيه الخاضعه للعقوبات لكن لمشكله
النفط في الولايات المتحده جانب وسبب مزمن
ايضا
ليست كلها من صنع اخطاء بيضا الذي يعرف
عنه اصلا توجهه نحو الطاقات المتجدده
بموازاه استراتيجيه خفض الاستثمارات في
قطاع استخراج النفط وتكريره فالادارات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه في العقدين الماضيين
اهملت قضيه صيانه واستثمار مصافي تكرير
النفط
متلو بايدا يسر الديمقراطيون على
استراتيجيات تحديد سقف مرتفع لمواصفات
الوقود تتسبب بمشاكل في الامدادات وارتفاع
الاسعار بالطبع بالارقام ايضا تراجع عدد
المصافي 13 بالمئه خلال عشر سنوات رقم هو
الادنى
ارتفاع الاسعار في الولايات المتحده يعود
الى نقص القدره على تحويل النفط الى وقود
وبالتالي تراجع المعروض في السوق الداخليه
بالارقام شكل الهامش بين اسعار النفط
الخام والمنتجات المكرره نحو 20 دولارا
نقلتها الحرب الاوكرانيه الى عتبه السبعين
دولارات
عامل اخر يضع بثقله المعنوي العلاقه
السيئه بين بيض وشركات النفط الامريكيه
الجمهوريون يتهمون الرئيسه بالاضرار
بشركات النفط العملاقه واذ قال قدره
انتاجها بالضرائب المبالغ بها والقيود
القانونيه والتشريعيه اذا اضفنا الى سلسله
هذه المشاكل الداخليه عامل الطبيعه اعني
هنا الاعاصير التي تتسبب بتوقف مصافي
التكرير او تراجع قدرتي التكرير فيها ايضا
يعود انخفاض مخزون البنزين الى اغلاق
المصافي بحجه عدم ربحتها الكبيره لماذا لم
تعد مربحه بسبب القوانين البيئيه الصارمه
والضرائب كما اشعرنا فالمشكله اذا تقنيه
بحث لكنها لماذا اخذت هذا البعض والسجال
الذي وصل الى حد اتهام قرار اوبك كلاس
لا يتحمل بيض مسؤوليه اسعار الطاقه وفق
بلومبرج هناك عوامل عده متعلقه به لعب
دورا مهما خصوماته لشركات النفط وتعهده
بوقف استخدام الوقود الاحفوري ضمن مجموعه
من العوامل الاخرى طبعا افقدت قدره السوق
طاقه الامريكيه على التعامل بمرونه مع
صدمات الاسعار
لسوء حظي الرئيس
مع امتحان انتخابين لولايته في الثامن من
نوفمبر
سلاح سياسي بوجه سلعه حيويه اقتصاديه بحث
ليس لامريكا فحسب بل للعلم
ومع تزايد القلق في دوائر صنع القرار
الامريكيه من تغيير اراده الناخبين عبر
عوامل خارجيه افاد تقرير لشبكه ام بي سي
نيوز الامريكيه ان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدرالي اف بي اي انشا محطات لمراقبه
التدخل الاجنبي المحتمل في انتخابات
التجديد النصفي للكونغرس واوضح التقرير ان
مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه انشا مكاتب
تتبع او تتبعوا التدخل داخل مقره في
واشنطن وفي 56 مكتبه اقليميه في جميع
انحاء البلاد واضاف تقرير ام بي سي نيوز
ان اف بي اي يشعر بالقلق اذا التدخل
الاجنبي المحتمل في الانتخابات من قبل
روسيا والصين وايران
هذا وتشكل ولايه اريزونا اعزائي المشاهدين
التي تشهدوا منافسه محتدمه تشكل مثالا على
مشهد الانقسام السياسي الذي تعيشه
الولايات المتحده في هذه الانتخابات حيث
تخوض مرشحه جمهوريه مدعومه من الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب الانتخابات مقابل
مرشحه اخرى ديموقراطيه يدعمها الرئيس
الامريكي الاسبق باراك اوباما واعداء
ترامب في الحزب الجمهوريه
الريزونا تجره واحده من اكثر معارك
انتخابات التجديد النصفي تنافسيه على منصب
الحاكم بين الجمهوريه كاريك والديمقراطيه
كيتي وبينهما الكثير من الاستقطاب
كاريك هي نجمه الحزب الجمهوري الجديده
اختارها ترامب بنفسه لخوض السباق وتتبنى
خطابه بتزوير انتخابات عام 2020 بكل قوه
انا السيده زينب
[تصفيق]
الرئيس على بطاقه ترامب اذا قرر خوض سباق
عام 2014
[موسيقى]
السباق يحمل صراعا اخر داخل الحزب الاحمر
التي تشارك في تحقيقات اقتحام الكبتل
وتسببت ترامب في خسارتها الانتخابات
التمهيديه لهذا السبب تدعمه ايضا يدعمها
النائب الجمهوري ادم كنزنجر الذي يشارك في
تحقيقات الكابيتل ووفر على نفسه اهانه
خساره الانتخابات التمهيديه باعلانه عدم
الترشح مجددا
استطلاعات الراي لم تحسمه هويه الفائز في
سباق حاكم اريزونا افضليه بسيطه للغايه
للمرشحه للجمهوريه تدعمه انتقادات للمرشحه
الديمقراطيه التي ترفض اجراء مناظره ويؤكد
معارضها انها خائفه من احراج علني
[موسيقى]
هدير بقي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
سمر
المتابعه اذهب الى نيفادا المجاوره
لاريزونا تنضم الى هناك مراسله العربيه
اي تحديثات للاخبار والارقام وفيما خصنا
نانسي فلوس هل حسمت مساله تنحيها ناديه
همم من رئاسه مجلس النواب الامريكي ايا
تكون نتيجه هذه الانتخابات النصفيه ام لا
هذا الامر لم يحسم بعد بشكل نهائي
اهلا بك طالب في الواقع انا كنت اريد ان
احتفظ بهذه الجزئيه لاحدثك عنها قبل قليل
هناك اخبار غير مؤكده لكن هناك توقعات
قويه بان تتنحى نانسي فلوسي اليوم
ستعلن عن تقاعدها وبالتالي تحافظ على
سجلها على مدى عقدين كما ذكرت كامراه
استطاعت ان تضم ربما جناحي الحزب المعتدل
والتقدمي وهذا امر الصعب جدا في مجلس
النواب الذي يضم 435 صوتا هي قالت في
المقابله التي ذكرتها في سيانين بانها
تاثرت بالحادث الذي تعرض له زوجها وكانت
هي المستهدفه بالدرجه الاولى وبالتالي
نانسي فلوسي ستغيب عن مجلس النواب هذه
المراه التي ارتبط يعني اسمها وفعلها
بالكثير من الانجازات لن تكون موجوده
والتوقعات كما ذكرت هو ان يسيطر
الجمهوريين على المجلس وبالتالي سيكون
لدينا شخص جديد
كيف المقاسي وهو ايضا من ولايه كاليفورنيا
لكنه محافظ احيانا يتبع للرئيس ترامب
احيانا يبتعد بعض الخطوات يعني يبقى على
مسافه من الرئيس ترامب لكن هذه توقعات حتى
الان بان نانسي فلوسي ستعلن عن تقاعدها
وتغيب عن المشهد السياسي الامريكي والرئي
سبايدر طبعا كما تعرف اليوم هو موجود في
ولايه ميلان يحاول اقناع الناخبين بان
الديمقراطيه هي على ورقه الانتخاب ليس فقط
القضايا الاساسيه التي يقول الديمقراطيه
بانها مهمه جدا مثل الاجهاض الرعايه
الصحيه او الضمان الاجتماعي حمل السلاح
المناخ وغيرها الى جانب الاقتصاد
قبل ان انتقل الى باختصار طب ولكن في حال
عم نقول في حال هذا سؤال في الغيث في حال
فاز الديمقراطيون مجددا في مجلس النواب من
هي الشخصيه المرشحه لتبوء منصب نانسي
صعب ااا وحتى جدولا يمكن ان نقول بانه صعب
جدا ان ان يفوز الديمقراطين اقول لك لماذا
طالب لانه الجمهوريه بحاجه الى خمس مقاعد
فقط وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن موجه حمراء
بمعنى 26 مقعد او فقط خمسه لتامين اغلبيه
ضئيله وبالتالي الجواب يعني لن يكون له
فائده لانه نتوقع بالفعل الا تكون هناك
مفاجاه على الاطلاق في مجلس النواب
المفاجاه في مجلس الشيوخ سيكون هناك بعض
الشخصيات ليست امراه لانه كما ذكرت هي
الوحيده التي دخلت التاريخ من اوسع ابوابه
كان ثالث امراه في تقود الولايات المتحده
يعني بعد الرئيس ولاعب رئيس هي التي تتولى
القياده وبالتالي سيكون شخص اخر سيختاره
الديمقراطيين لن يكون قياديا بحجم وهمم
ربما كانت نانسي فلوسي لكن هذه توقعات
ربما لن تترجم الى افعال لانه كبن مقاطع
نادي ابقي معي انتقل الى اريد سليمان ريتا
اا جديد المشهد من عندك ما الذي لا فتك
حتى الساعه وماذا تقول اخر استطلاعات
الراي خصوصا ان الرئيس بايدن الان في
الخبر العاجل يستصرخ الناخبين للادلاء
باصواتهم بكثافه اكيد للحزب الديمقراطي ما
الذي لا فتك وهل لعب كلا الحزبين جميع
الاوراق ام لا يعني بعد في الوقت الضائع
يمكن ان يبرز اي من الحسبين ورقه رابحه ام
لا يعني اللي ضرب ضرب والهرب هرب كما يقول
المثل اللبناني
المعركه بين الطرفين بين الحزبين استمرت
طويلا في اريزونا
واتخذت شكلا
حاسما ايضا اليوم بدا التصويت وكان هناك
اقبال كبير من المواطنين في اريزونا على
التصويت وايضا في اتصالنا مع همم فريق همم
مرشح الجمهوري لمنصب المدعي العام ابراهيم
حماده كان هناك قالوا لنا بان هناك بعض
المراكز التي كان فيها خلل تقني منع
المواطنين من التصويت فيها
وكان هناك دعوه من
الحزب الجمهوري له مواطن يهبل انتظار في
هذه المناطق في هذه المراكز تحديدا همم
بانتظار الاصلاح الخطا واعاده التصويت مره
جديده همم فقط لعدم حصول اي اشكاليه
تمنعهم من احتساب
اصواتهم هذا من ابرز
النقاط التي تابعناها فيما خاص المعركه
همم بين الحزب الجمهوري والديمقراطي في
اريزونا فهي حاميه جدا منذ اسابيع وحتى
اشهر خاصه مع همم زعم المرشحين الجمهوريين
للمناصب الثلاثه الكبيره في همم الولايه
بتزوير الانتخابات السابقه التي ادت الى
فوز الرئيس فيها
وخاصه في معركه حاكم الولايه التي تترشح
في التي تنافس همم تتنافس فيها همم كاريك
همم
الديمقراطيه
المعركه همم شديده بين السيده تين جدا
واتهامات متبادله
الاقتصاد وارتفاع نسب الجريمه
الى نادي هل سيسلمل الجميع بنتيجه هذه
الانتخابات املا بعض الرؤوس الحاميه ان صح
التعبير خصوصا ما سمعناه من بعض حكام
الولايات بانهم لن يسلموا بنتائج هذه
الانتخابات وتعيد الامور سيرتها الاولى
كما جرى في الانتخابات الرئاسيه الماضيه
يعني حتى الساعه الرئيس دونالد ترامب لم
يسلم بخسارته وهل هنالك هذا السيناريو
مطروح
المرشحه لابرز ربما ااه عن الحزب الجمهوري
في الولايه همم
قالت مرارا وتكرارا بانها لم تقبل سوى
بنتيجه واحده وهي نتيجه فوزها في
الانتخابات وهي تؤكد ذلك ايضا في حين
تتهمها المرشحه الديمقراطيه كيتي هوبز
بانها جندت عدد من
المتحمسين الجمهوريين لتعنيف الناخبين
الديمقراطيين وهذا جدل ايضا دائر الان في
الارينا
الخبر العاجل انه رئيس بايجن دائما عم
يكرر يستصرخ الناخبين للادلاء باصواتهم
للحزب الديمقراطي هل تبدو لك هذه استغاثه
متاخره او صرخه ببريه لان الوقت قد فات
للفوز بما هو ات هذا واحد اثنين في حال
سيناريو يعني اللي هو النايت ماير بالنسبه
الى الديمقراطيين في حال خسروا مجلس
النواب ومجلس الشيوخ هل سيناريو ان يقوم
الحزب الديمقراطي
بسحب ترشح الرئيس
للرئاسه مط ام لا هذا صعب وربما مستحيل
لا ما تروح بشكل كبير يعني هذه الانتخابات
حتى قبل صدور النتائج هي استفتاء على اداء
الرئيس بايدن همم توقع الخساره في مجلس
النواب معروفه اصلا الرئيس اوباما خسر
الاغلبيه والرئيس ترامب ايضا خسر الاغلبيه
في مجلس النواب لكن اذا خسر الديمقراطين
في مجلس الشيوخ اعتقد بان هناك اصوات في
داخل الحزب الديمقراطي ستقول للرئيس بان
عليه التنحي واعطاء الفرصه لشخص اخر دم
دماء جديده بالنهايه سيكون الرئيس اكبر
رئيس امريكا يدخل التاريخ اذا ترشح
للولايه الثانيه وبالتالي ستكون هناك بعض
الاصوات التي تحث على التنحي جانبا هذا
بالنسبه للسؤال الثاني بس بالنسبه للسؤال
الاول كما تعرف هذه الانتخابات نتحدث على
انها او توصيف لها بانها مصيريه بانها
تاريخيه بانها غير مسبوقه الى اخره ايضا
نذكر بانها الاولى بعد احداث اقتحام
الكونجرس خلفي هذا
مركز المرموق رمز الديمقراطيه الامريكيه
ياتي لهذه الانتخابات هي المره الاولى
وبالتالي هناك بالفعل من نجح في بث نظريه
المؤامره بان الانتخابات الامريكيه مشكه
بها
وخصوصا المدعومين من قبل الرئيس ترامب
الذين يقولون اذا لم نفز في هذه
الانتخابات معناها بان الانتخابات مزيفه
اذا فزنا معناها بين الانتخابات نزيهه ومن
هنا ايضا يا استفتاء على اداء الرئيس
ترامب الذي ينتظر ينتظر الان النتائج
ليعلن ترشحه مسبقا ويحجم كل خصومه بما فيه
نائب الرئيس وزير الخارجيه مايك بنسوون
مايكل وايضا حاكم فلوريدا همم
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه شكرا ايضا
من همم نيفادا بالمجاوره لاريزونا كانت
معي ايضا مراسله العربيه للتسليها شكرا
جزيلا لك رد على هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
جهاز جهاز
الانتخابات في اريزونا لها جانب اخر فهناك
خسرت ترامب عام 2020 حينما قرر المصون
معاقبته على الاساءه للسنه الراحل جون
ماكين
الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه عام 2020
شهدت فوزا غير متوقع المرشح الديمقراطيس
على نظيره الجمهوري دونالد ترامب في عده
الولايات عرفت بعضها سابقا بالولاء للحزب
الجمهوريته
لم يكن لمجرد تاييد الناخبين لكن كانت
درسا قاسيا قدمهم الناخب الجمهوري لترامب
زعلان
[موسيقى]
حزب الجمهوري وباتت ارينا ساحه معركه في
الصراع الداخلي الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب كان في مواجهه جون ماكين السيناتور
الطويل الخدمه في ولايه ارينا مكان عرف
عنه انه من اشد منتقد وبقي معارضا له حتى
وفاته في اغسطس 2018
[موسيقى]
وفي احد خطابات ترامب عام 2019 زله لسان
للرئيس السابق كلفته كرسيه البيت الابيض
عام 2020 بعد اهانته السيناتور الرحل جم
ماكين الذي يعتبره الجمهوريون في ارينا
وطلع حرب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الان مقعد جون ماكين في مجلس الشيوخ عن
ولايه اريزونا مطروح في انتخابات التجديد
النصفيه لا يمكن التقاضي عن سيطره ترامب
على حزب الجمهوري في ولايه اريزونا التي
يخوض بلاك ماستر
قوي من الرئيس السابق انتخابات على مقعده
الا انه لا يعرف هل تصوت ولايه اريزونا
لمرشح الجمهوريه مؤيدا لترامب ان تكرر
سيناريو انتخابات 2020
وتواصل انتقامها لمكان
الان المفاصل قصير نتابع بعده وهذه
التغطيه للانتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معك
[موسيقى]
زي المشاهدين اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى
هذه الصور التي تردنا مباشره للرئيس
الامريكيه السابق دونالد ترامب فيف بالم
بيتش في فلوريدا حيث ادلى بصوت
منذ قليل حسب ما يقال لي
بالطبع هو هو
زوجته رئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
بالطبع البعض يرى في هذه الانتخابات بانها
استفتاء حقيقي ومباشر على شعبيات الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب من اجل عوده قويه في
انتخابات 20 همم 24
ساحاول ان اسال ضيوف بعد قليل همم عن همم
هذه همم المساله ولكن نبقى مع هذه الصور
همم بالصوت
وماذا سيقول الرئيس دونالد ترامب
لكن رائعه
[موسيقى]
ذلك بسرعه
تتدفق الى بلادنا بلاد الدمر فهذا سيحصل
ولكن يجب ان نحارب الجريمه وانخفض ضرائب
ويجب ان افعل اشياء نحيه على الحدود ويجب
لكم كل ذلك الى الانثي
ين
شكرا لكم جميعا
حاضر حاضر
بالطبع الرئيس الامريكي السابق دون ترامب
وزوجته ميلانيا ترامب بعد ادلائه بصوته
همم في بالم بيتش في فلوريدا ابرز ما قاله
في اجابه على بعض اسئله الصحفيين على
الامريكيين الخروج والتصويت بقوه الان
سنخفض الضرائب في حين ان الديمقراطيين
يرغبون برفعها يجب ان نفعل شيئا حيال
حدودنا ومساله المهاجرين واا يعني الحديث
الساعه الان عما سيكون هنالك من مفاجات
يوم الثلاثاء القادم القاضي بالطبع همم
يتوقع الجميع او معظم المراقبين بان يعلن
يوم الثلاثاء القادم الرئيس السابق ترامب
ترشحه للانتخابات الرئاسيه 20 24 ولكن حتى
الساعه يعني همم ردوا على السؤال قال يوم
الثلاثاء القادم سيكون مشوقا للجميع يعني
يتجنب التاكيد مباشره همم حول هذه المساله
ما اذا كان سيترشح ام لا قال يوم الثلاثاء
القادم سيكون مشوقا لل الجميع
على كل المزيد من المتابعه مع من واشنطن
الان الخبير في الشان الامريكي والعلاقات
الدوليه ايهاب عباس وايضا الباحث في الشان
الامريكي ديفيد برمضان سيدي ايهاب عباس
اولا كيف تبعت هذه الانتخابات حتى الساعه
ما الذيتك
وسمعنا يعني تصريح اا الرئيس دونالد ترامب
منذ قليل بعد ادلائه بصوته في بالم بيتش
في فلوريدا هل تعتقد فعلا ان هذه
الانتخابات النصفيه هي استفتاء مباشر على
شعبيه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
وبالتالي حظوظه للترشح في للانتخابات
الرئاسيه في 20 24
اهلا بحضرتك وبضيف الكريم وبكل المشاهدين
الملاحظه ان هذه الانتخابات هناك محاولات
للقفز على
النتائج بصوره مبكره ويبدو ان هذا القفز
ياتي من جانب الحزب الديمقراطي
للاعلام بشكل او باخر ان التصويت
للديمقراطيين اكثر ااا وان النوع بيتقدمون
بفارق مالي عدد من الملايين من الاصوات في
تصوير المبكر يعلم كيف اعرف ذلك وعمليات
الفرز لم تتم الجزء الاخر وهو مساله
الاستفتاء هل هو استفتاء على الرئيس
السابق وشعبيته دونالد ترامب انا اعتقد
انها مساله الاستفتاء على الرئيس اين على
السابق وشعبيته وعلى الحالي وادائه خلال
العامين الماضيين ونعلم جميعا ان هناك عدد
من الملفات الداخليه والخارجيه اثرت بشكل
مباشر على المواطن الامريكي وحياته
اليوميه ما ادى الى حدوث ما نشاهده من
حاله تضخم
ارتفاع نسب الفائده في الفيدرالي الامريكي
محاوله لمواجهه هذا التضخم بشكل همم فشل
معه حتى الان
وبالاضافه طبعا لارتفاع اسعار الوقود
وانقلاب الرئيس جو بايدن على شركات النفط
التي يريد ان يفرض عليها المزيد من
الضرائب ربما الغرامات وعدم اعطائها الفرص
مزيد من التنقيب داخل الولايات المتحده
وهو يخسر بذلك قطاعه كبير جدا يتجاوز
السته او من سته ل 10 ملايين اشخاص يعملون
في هذا القطاع بشكل مباشر او بشكل غير
مباشر سوق الاداره في الملفات الخارجيه
ايضا له تاثير اصبح المواطن الامريكي يهتم
بما يحدث خارج البلاد لانه بدا يدرك ان اا
هذه الحوادث الخارجيه تؤثر على جيبه في
نهايه المطاف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
والدعم اللام متناهي من اداره
الاعداء مع همم الصين في شكل تايوان
وغيرها والاستفزازات الموجوده بالاضافه
الى التعامل همم
الناعم جدا من اداره بادن مع الملف
الايراني الخطير وعدم همم يعني وقوف
الولايات المتحده كاداره ديمقراطيه لا
اريد لا اريد ان اقول الولايات المتحده
كلها لكن الاداره ديمقراطيه بشكل المناسب
للحلفاء الاستراتيجيين لها على مستوى
العالم في مختلف البقاء ومن بينها طبعا
طيب طاقه الشرق الاوسط دعنا ينتقل السيد
بدي السيد ايضا السؤال الموجه اليك كيف
تبعت حتى الساعه مجريات هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه ما الذي لفتتك وما الذي تخشاه
يعني في البعض الان يخشى انه همم كثير من
حكام الولايات او بعض المرشحين لا يسلموا
بنتائج الانتخابات خصوصا شخصيات ديمقراطيه
اعلنت ذلك انه او هي بتفوز او الانتخابات
هذه مزوره هل هنالك خشيه فعليه ان تتكرر
في بعض الولايات سيناريو الانتخابات
الرئاسيه همم الماضيه ام لا يعني هذا
الكلام غير صحيح
نعم الطالب شكرا للاستضافه ليك هذه
مناورات سياسيه ستغيب الشمس اليوم على
امريكا وتشرق غدا
ونعاود حياتنا الطبيعيه وفي اوائل العام
القادم يستلم كل من انتخب الليله مكانه
الطبيعي ان كان في الكونجرس او كان في
مجلس شيوخ او كان في الولايات كحكام
القانون والمحاكم هي التي ستسلم هذه
الانتخابات لكل من ربح الانتخابات سيكون
هناك كلام كثير سيكون هناك الكثير من
المناورات السياسيه همم راينا ما حصل في
الانتخابات السابقه في رئاسه الجمهوريه
ولكن نهار الاستلام والتسليم شاء ابا من
خسرا سيسلم الانتخابات لمن ربحه هذه هي
امريكا هذه الديمقراطيه وهذا حكم القانون
في هذه الولايات الامريكيه المتحده طيب
همم استاذ ايهاب طيب
يقول لك انه لا في حال فاز حتى لو فاز
الجمهوريون فان الرئيس الامريكي يبقى
الرئيس الشخص القوي في النظام الامريكي
ولن يكون بطه عرجاء كما يريد الجمهوريون
همم له في السنتين المقبلين هو يبقى لديه
صلاحيات واسعه ولا يمكن التقليل من هذه
الصلاحيه ما رايك بهذا الكلام
يعني بكل تاكيد لديه صلاحيات واسعه ولاديه
القوانين التنفيذيه يستطيع ان يستخدمها
ولكن هذا سيؤثر بشكل كبير اذا كان هذا
الاستخدام في الاتجاه الخاطئ سيؤثر على
شعبييه ديمقراطيين فيما تبقى له من سنتين
في البيت الابيض واعتقد انه همم لا ينظر
الى الامور بهذا الشكل متناهي الصغر لانه
يعلم انه بعد عام تقريبا من الان ستبدا مع
مع ارهاصات للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
سواء كانت سيترشح هو لها او سترشح اي همم
مرشح ديمقراطي اخر وبالتالي يجب ان يكون
هناك موازنات ومؤامات في عمليه استخدام
الصلاحيات الواسعه للرئيس يعني بذلك انه
اذا ما فاز الجمهوريون بالكونجرس بمجلسيه
او باحداهما فقط ستكون هناك طبعا بكل
تاكيد همم مواقف متصادمه مع البيت الابيض
خاصه وعلى راسها مساله الدعم اللام متناهي
له اوكرانيا طيب نعلم ان كيف المقال في
زعيم الاغلبيه في مجلس النواب عبر عفوا
الاقليه في مجلس النواب الجمهوريه طبعا
قال ذلك صراحه لن نكتب شيكا على بياض
اوكراني لا اقول ان الدعم سيتوقف
متى يكون قليلا جدا
لانهي مع السيد ديفيد
الكل ينتظر الان همم الثلاثاء القادم ماذا
سيقوم به الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
السيناريو الاولى يقول انه اذا فاز همم
الجمهوريون فب- بالطبع سيعلن ترشحه بشكل
قوي ولكن في حال كانت هنالك مفاجات ولم
يفوز همم
الجمهوريون خصوصا يعني في مجلس همم الشيوخ
وما باعرف اذا في مجلس النواب عن انه صعب
جدا مجلس النواب يفوز الديمقراطيون كما
تقول استطلاعات رائد ولكن هل ترى انه يوم
الثلاثاء خلاص الرئيس دونالد ترامب اي ان
تكون النتائج سيعلن ترشحه ام لا لماذا
ينتظر حتى الثلاثاء
النتائج اليوم ستكون من صالح الحزب
الجمهوري
سيربح الجمهوريين مجلس النواب في الكونجرس
وعلى الارجح سيربح الجمهوريين الاكثريه في
مجلس الشيوخ ولو كانت هذه الاكثاريه في
كلا
المجلسين ستكون اكثريه صغيره جدا في مجلس
الشيوخ بصوت واحد او صوتين في مجلس النواب
بحدود 10 او ال20 طيب همم لذلك هذا هذه
النتائج شبه محسومه اليوم اللي ضرب ضرب
المسج مرئيت وصار اليوم دور همم
الانتخابات انها تسير هذا سيؤثر ليس
بالضروره على
قراره بنك همم رئيس امريكا السابق اخذ
قراره
بالترشحه
هنالك الكثير من المناورات داخل الحزب
وسماعنا امبارح
همم رئيسه الحزب الجمهوري انه اذا ترشح
رئيس الجمهوريه لن يستطيع الحزب الجمهوري
همم ان يدفع تكاليفه القانونيه
لعده همم
اعتقد وسط الرساله للاسف للاسف انتهى
الوقت السيد رمضان همم الباحث في الشان
الامريكي شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
للخبير في همم الامريكي والعلاقات الدوليه
ايهاب عباس كان معي ايضا من واشنطن
ولايه اوهايو اعزائي المشاهدين تعتبر من
اهم الولايات في الانتخابات النصفيه
الامريكيه استشهدوا سباقا تنافيا للغايه
على منصب مقعد مجلس الشيوخي فيها وقد يحدد
الفائز بهذا المقعد هويه الاغلبيه في
المجلس
تقول القاعده العامه في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه انك لا تستطيع الفوز
اذا لم تفوز باهايو لم يتمكن اي رئيس
امريكي من كسر هذه القاعده منذ جون كندي
الا مرشح وحيد جويدر عام 2020 رغم ذهاب
اوهايو الى ترامب
مجددا تصبح اوهاي محطه الانظار في
الانتخابات النصفيه خصوصا في التنافس على
مجلس الشيوخ
السنه الجمهوري روبرت بورتمان الذي ضل في
مقعد سنه لولايتين قرر عدم الترشح مجددا
ليفتح باب منافسه شرسه بين الحزبين
الجمهوريون يريدون الاحتفاظ بالمقعد في
سعيهم للسيطره على مجلس الشيوخ
والديمقراطيون يريدون اضافه المقعد لهم
لنفس السبب
يتنافس على منصب السيناتور رجل الاعمال
والمحامي والمؤلف الجمهوري جديبانس وعضو
مجلس النواب الديمقراطي تمرين
لكن السباق يشبه انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه لعام 2016 حيث يدعم دونالد
ترامب وبكل قوه
ترامب دائما صاحب الحضور الطالب
مزاج هناك يميل قليلا الى الجمهوريين
انتخابات النصفيه الامريكيه استشهدوا
سباقا تنافوسيا للغايه على منصب مقعد مجلس
الشيوخ فيها وقد يحدد الفائز بهذا المقعد
هويه الاغلبيه في المجلس كما ذكرنا منذ
قليل
في تكساس يفصل بين المكسيكيين على جانبي
الحدود مع امريكا ما هو اعمق واضخم من هذا
الجدار
فهناك من حالفهم الحظ وانتقلوا شمالا لارض
الاحلام كما يحلو لهم تسميتها وهناك من
يقف في طوابير انتظار او يبحث عن ثغره
دخولا غير قانونيه
الجمهوريه ماريا فلوريس هي اول سيده ولدت
في المكسيك ثم هاجرت الى امريكا لتصبح
نائبه في الكونغرس والان تسعى لاعاده
انتخابها ورسالاتها هي اغلق الحدود
اثناء الحديث بالانجليزيه لكنها تحرص على
ابراز المظهر المفضل للناخب الجمهوري
وترديد الرساله التي يحب الاستماع لها كما
تحظى بشعبيه بين ابناء عرقها من
اللاتينيين
الجنس
[موسيقى]
المهاجرين القادم
طبعا انا من الجيش
مضمونه للحزب الديمقراطي لكن في جنوب
تكساس الوضع ليس كذلك حيث يرى من يسكن
المناطق الحدوديه منهم ان سياسه بيضا
للهجره تنشروا الفوضى في اماكن معيشتها
التغطيه مستمره ااا من العربيه على مدى
الساعات القادمه ولكن حتى الساعه اطب
تحيات مني والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]